right well let's bring you some breaking
news now and the climate researchers
well climate researchers from the UN
have warned that it's now considerably
more likely than not that global warming
will breach the key one and a half
degree limit established by the Paris
2015 agreement that's within the next
five years let's bring in our climate
change correspondent Hannah Thomas fetus
who's in The Newsroom for us so this is
from the World Meteorological
organization Hannah it is and it's a
sobering warning it's the first time
that these scientists have said and they
make a yearly prediction on this that
it's more likely than not that we will
temporarily breach the 1.5 degrees
temperature threshold by
2027. they've also warned that Arctic
heating is going to is likely to be
three times faster than the rest of the
world and that it's 98 likely that at
least one of the next five years is
going to be the warmest on record so why
is this why has the prediction suddenly
jumped from 50 likelihood of exceeding
1.5 to 66 likelihood of exceeding 1.5
well emissions continue to rise they are
heading in the wrong direction and with
those Rising emissions heat is going up
to last year was one of the warmest on
record we've seen droughts in the
southern us we've seen ongoing droughts
in Europe and problems with the water
table where already at around 1.2
degrees of warming as you can see from
our climate data sheet there but the
other issue on top of emissions heading
in the wrong direction is the return of
the El Nino weather phenomenon which
tends to be associated with warming
ocean temperatures and warming air
temperatures now as I said at the
beginning of this report the scientists
did say that it was worrying but but
potentially temporary that we exceed 1.5
and that is because if there is a sharp
reduction in emissions it could well
head back in the correct direction but
this is a really symbolic moment the
first time we've been this close to
exceeding 1.5 potentially and remember
this is 1.5 number is the number around
which all of the climate discussions
have rotated the number that diplomats
have been holding on to tightly because
they fear that without agreement that
1.5 degrees is still possible
people will go in their own directions
big oil and other fossil fuel generators
will have permission to continue to emit
carbon and that we will lose the center
of gravity that has proved so important
in climate discussions and Global
agreements so far
okay Hannah thank you so much